Speaker 1: Marjorie Taylor GREENE did
something which, had it been done by
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez, they would be calling
for her head. What did Marjorie Taylor GREENE do?
Well, she went on Tucker Carlson's Fox News
program. And just assailed New York City,
saying it's disgusting, saying it's dirty, saying
it smells bad, that people are dying from drugs
on the street. And all of this is because Marjorie
Taylor GREENE is furious that on Tuesday she went
and tried to have a protest in support of Donald
Trump in the context of Trump being arrested on
Tuesday in New York City. And she was run out of
the place. Just run out of the place. A whistles.
You couldn't even hear what she was saying. Nobody
wanted her there more media than supporters.
And so now she says it's disgusting and it's
disastrous and it's all horrible. Just imagine
if this was AOC saying it about a city in Marjorie
Taylor Greene's district. Here is what she had
to say to Tucker Carlson. And it won't shock you
that Tucker Carlson looks concerned and confused,
which is generally always the look on his face.
Speaker 4: Really quick, since you were just
there, but you described New
York as, quote, his home. How
did his homework? Pretty neat and tidy.
Speaker 2: No, his home is disgusting.
I compared it to what I called Gotham City. The
streets are filthy. They're covered with people
basically dying on drugs. They can't even stand
up. They're falling over. There's so much crime in
the city. I can't. I can't comprehend how people
live there. It was repulsive. It smells bad. And
I just I think it's a terrible place.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
There's a lot that we could say here. I'm not even
going to delve into the reality that there is an
opioid epidemic that is in the south of the United
States. There's a meth epidemic. I mean, listen,
there's there are addiction problems in all sorts
of parts of this country. And Marjorie Taylor
GREENE is part of the country, isn't exempt.
But understand that this is her anger because
their protest lasted two and a half minutes before
she was just run out of there by hecklers because
nobody wanted her in New York City. We don't want
Marjorie Taylor GREENE back in New York. And it
sounds like from what she's saying, we shouldn't
expect to see her again. But it's really important
also to point out that the entire New York City is
disgusting. Meme is pretty played out. The truth
is that New York City has a lower crime rate
than many other cities in the United States,
including cities run by Republicans like Oklahoma
City and even some cities. And Marjorie Taylor.
GREENE Never mind Marjorie Taylor GREENE
State, Marjorie Taylor Green's district,
which we are going to get to. It's not really
groundbreaking news that when there is a high
population density, sometimes you see more
trash in different places. And this, of course,
applies to any place that has that number of
people. It's not really groundbreaking. It
doesn't really say much about Eric Adams. But just
think for a second. If AOC went on MSNBC and said,
I went down to I don't know, I'm not going to pick
on I'm not picking on Dalton, Georgia. But Dalton,
Georgia is in Marjorie Taylor. GREENE The district
I went down with, Rachel MADDOW. AOC tell us,
what was it like down in Marjorie Taylor Green's
district? I went down to Dalton, Georgia,
and the crime rate is way higher than New York
City. It was disgusting. The average income per
capita isn't even $22,000. There's no jobs. There
is no money. It's filled with these dirty textile
polluting industry buildings. Only 70% of the
population in Dalton even has a high school
diploma, compared to 85% in New York City. It was
terrible, disgusting place. Imagine if AOC did
that on MSNBC about Dalton. AOC and everyone
on the right would be saying they constantly
insult our part of the country. They think that
we're stupid. They think this. They think that.
They think we're backwards. Imagine how the right
would be reacting if AOC had done what Marjorie
Taylor GREENE did about New York City. But there
is a difference. The difference is that it's now
popular to say this sort of stuff about New York
City, even when you're not really breaking any
new ground. So the real disgusting aspect to
this is Marjorie Taylor. GREENE That's what I
find truly deplorable. Not Manhattan, which is not
exactly a hellscape the way she makes it out to be